yes breaking news uh Jonathan in the
last few minutes the Rishi sunak team
have claimed to Sky News that they have
indeed uh topped reached a hundred the
reason there's a difference in the
figures uh our official figures are
those who have publicly declared uh the
uh the total the bigger number of
presumably is some that have not gone
public yet although the tsunac team are
claiming they've got a hundred pledges
already now as for Boris Johnson's
supporters they claim they're up to 68
Which is higher than the figure we're
creating because some of those have not
gone public in the last hour or so
things have been moving really fast
there's been a flurry of names declaring
for Rishi sulak in the past hour or so
Matt Hancock former cabinet Minister
Oliver Dowden former party chairman and
uh cabinet minister Tobias Elwood now
significantly he has switched from Penny
mortens who he backed in the summer and
Tom tugenhart the security minister all
coming out for Rishi sunac as well as
Sajid Javid as well he backed Liz truss
last time Boris Johnson supporters well
they include Sir John wittingdale newly
a knighted a cabinet minister under Mr
Johnson Senior Euro Skeptics like Sir
Bill cash in the last hour or so as well
it's becoming a two-horse race rather
than a three-horse race it seems a penny
Morton is struggling uh she's not
picking up new supporters late this
evening but Mr sunac is powering ahead
in terms of numbers not over yet of
course he was ahead amongst MPS last
time round ended up coming second but at
the moment Mr sunac is doing very well
amongst MPS picking up Summer Penny
Morden supporters it seems Boris Johnson
well he's told his supporters I'm up for
it I'm gonna do it dudders he said to uh
Sir James dudridge one of his key
supporters when I asked Sir James are
you going to get to 100 nominations he
said 100 percent yes absolutely